Oh another round no I think I'm good
it's open bar
another us come on
a fun night yeah I don't even care we
win oh yeah of course totally but I'm
saying even if we don't win yeah we're
good yeah no I know
same page I'm just saying that you know
I'm so proud of the work that we've done
that I don't need the validation of my
peers to me to feel good about it yeah
but we're gonna win yes
Hey for Boston Coolidge put some boos at
him I have a 4:00 White Russians maybe
put some booze in that yeah you know
what for more Boston coolers no boots I
think about you know what's invisible
wow you guys must be thirsty
Carter Carter grant VP of Marketing
Chrysler al not anymore
oh you changed your name no same name
I actually got fired what happened well
I've hit a string of bad luck as of late
it all started with that accident I was
in you guys remember that
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't ring a bell